[Applaus]
[Musik]
die FIFA ist eine richtige Geldmaschine
das ist natürlich eine riesen
Überraschung Katar 22 eine Wahl
überschattet von Korruptionsvorwürfen
in us-akten finden wir brisante Aussagen
eines Kronzeugen
wir wissen von Korruptionsvorwürfen dank
eines Kronzeugen der darüber detailliert
ausgesandt hat
und wir stellen fest seine Aussagen über
Katha Korruption tauchen in einem Urteil
der FIFA Ethikkommission auf nobody
lassen Sie mich festhalten der
Vertrauensmissbrauch ist empörend das
Ausmaß der Korruption unvorstellbar
Verhaftungen im Zürcher Nobelhotel
borolak die fifa-affäre platzt vor den
Augen der Öffentlichkeit
auf jeden Fall haben die Amerikaner Test
gemacht was sie gut können sie haben
auch die Spur des Geldes aufgenommen die
Schweiz gerät in den Strudel der
fifa-affäre der Anfang eines riesigen
justizkandals im Fokus der Bundesanwalt
das ist eine große Zahl ein sehr großer
Fall für die Bundesanwaltschaft es waren
auf der Seite ich werde alles dafür tun
dass uns dieser Fall nicht überfordert
es ist einfach unendlich kompliziert das
sind über 1.000 Seiten Protokoll
us-gerichtsprotokolle Urteile interne
Unterlagen
und wir finden auch einen
Bundesgerichtsentscheid der sich als
sehr aufschlussreich erweisen wird
wer aber wusste in der FIFA von diesen
Hinweisen über gekaufte Stimmen und
weshalb hat die FIFA nicht gehandelt
wir kontaktieren den FIFA-Präsidenten
Jenny Infantino
und wollen Antworten auf unsere Fragen
[Musik]
wir ein SHG Journalistenteam
recherchieren zu den
Korruptionsvorwürfen rund um Katar wir
alle haben Erfahrungen in diesen
Themengebieten der Westschweizer
Journalist Ludovic gedreht
seiner Interviewanfrage hat der
FIFA-Präsident damals abgelehnt
Janine ist zum besten Verkäufer der WM
in Katar geworden er beherrscht die
Kommunikation und kontrolliert sie wenn
man ihn um ein Interview bittet und er
weiß dass kritische Fragen kommen lehnt
er in der Regel ab general ihre Füße
[Musik]
es ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte
was hier entstanden ist und entwickelt
wurde ist großartig toll
eine WM der Superlative
acht Stadien neu gebaut eine Investition
von geschätzten 220 Milliarden Dollar
[Musik]
now
it's getting
Johannes
ich bin stolz und glücklich darüber dass
die Welt Katar sehen wird
[Applaus]
sehr weit mit seinen Bemühungen die WM
in Katar zu propagieren er ist mit
seiner Familie sogar nach Katar gezogen
offiziell so die FIFA damit er näher
beim
WM-Organisationskomitee sei aber wir
wissen dass bis heute kein
FIFA-Präsident also beispielsweise Herr
Blatter seinen Wohnsitz wegen einer WM
nach Südafrika oder nach Deutschland
verlegt hat
ein wüstenstart am Persischen Golf ein
Viertel so groß wie die Schweiz
[Musik]
wegen den hohen Temperaturen findet die
WM im Winter statt
alles klimaneutral betont Katha
[Musik]
ein Wüstenstaat ohne große
fußball-tradition organisiert eine
Fußball-WM
das Land schwimmt in Geld die
wichtigsten Einnahmequellen Erdöl und
vor allem Erdgas
[Musik]
eine Monarchie mit dem Emir an der
Spitze
[Musik]
langwierige Bewilligungsverfahren gibt
es keine
Frauen sind kaum sichtbar denn das
katarische Gesetz beruht auf der Scharia
[Musik]
90 Prozent der Bewohner sind nicht
Katara es sind Arbeitsmigranten
Bauarbeiter Hausangestellte ihre Rechte
sind eingeschränkt gegen außen gibt sich
das Land fortschrittlich
[Musik]
mit der jetzt feinen endlich ist der Tag
da ein arabischer Gastgeber für die WM
[Musik]
die WM-Vergabe an Katar zweifelhafter
Höhepunkt einer umstrittenen
fifa-geschichte
die Wahl von Katar im Jahr 2010 hat für
die FIFA in gewisser Weise den heutigen
Ärger verursacht FIFA wie ist es dazu
gekommen
wir tauchen ein in die Geschichte der
FIFA wir studieren Akten
Gerichtsunterlagen Protokolle
[Musik]
und ordnen alles chronologisch
scheinbar harmlose treffen erhalten
plötzlich eine neue Bedeutung
der lange Schatten der Korruption
mittendrin drei fußball-präsidenten im
Kampf um die Macht
Sepp Blatter
Michelle Platini
und Gianni Infantino
dieses Trio ein fatales Trio Blatter
Infantino Platini die drei Männer
sprechen heute nicht mehr miteinander
und sie beschuldigen sich gegenseitig
das komplettes
Verein mit Hauptsitz in Zürich
[Musik]
4,7 Milliarden Franken budgetierte
Einnahmen im Jahr 2022
alle Einnahmen würden zurück in den
Fußball fließen betont die FIFA eine
Non-Profit-Organisation
TV Screens im FIFA Museum
[Musik]
Fußball fasziniert die ganze Welt ein
Milliardengeschäft auch dank der
fifa-weltmeisterschaften alle vier Jahre
das Milliardengeschäft beginnt mit Sepp
Blatter
jahrelang prägt er die FIFA
17 Jahre lang als Generalsekretär und
weitere 17 als Präsident
[Musik]
Sepp Blatter Arbeiterkind katholisch
aufgewachsen im Wallis in seiner Jugend
leidenschaftlicher Fußballspieler
[Musik]
Offiziers Karriere
Wirtschaftsstudium dann Einstieg ins
professionelle sportgeschäft
dreimal verheiratet dreimal geschieden
deiner Mitmenschen ist Gradmesser deines
Erfolges sein Vorgänger heißt joa hier
rechts im Bild
[Musik]
wirtschaftliche Kraft worden so viele
Garten
Licher
automatischen politische Dimensionen und
das hätte
jetzt Zeit natürlich
die Politiker
begonnen hat das Monster in Paris
im Mai 1998 kandidiert Platter als FIFA
Präsident
Paris mit eurem Sportpolitik hat
besonders Afrika normal wie sieht der
Macht in Südafrika das sind ganz klare
ja stimme für die Zukunft vom Fußball
aber insbesondere bringen die Afrikaner
das Thema
genau das wenn sie der Johannson
bekommen mit
so nebenbei verspricht Platter Südafrika
bereits die WM
und er wird das Versprechen später auch
einlösen
sei es
der große Vorteil von mir ist ich
bekommeikativ ich habe mit den Retter
ich habe mit denen eigenen sprachreden
und das ist sehr wichtig
Blatter umgibt sich in Paris mit
zahlreichen Stars seine
außenseiterkandidatur erhält so
zusätzlichen Rückhalt
[Musik]
Wahlhelfer ist Michelle Platini einst
französischer Spitzenfußballer jetzt
erfolgreicher Fußball funktioniert
diese Freundschaft wird den beiden 17
Jahre später zum Verhängnis werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der FIFA Kongress
weltaussenseiterplatte zum neuen
Präsidenten
ich bin überwältigt wirklich überwältigt
und schon taucht der erste Schatten der
Korruption auf von Kuverts voller Geld
ist die Rede von gekauften afrikanischen
stimmen die SRG konfrontiert ihn damals
mit den Gerüchten
in der Bar afrikanische Delegierte der
Blatter vertraute
wer bezahlte ihre Flüge
Transport Flüge Hotel alles bezahlt von
Herrn bienham aus Katar
es war fantastisch der aßen
Krokodilfleisch ergab uns die Kraft für
Herrn Blatter zu kämpfen
hat man ihnen etwas versprochen für ihre
blatterstimme
ja und was er versprach uns Geld
alles ohne Folgen für Blatter und seinen
Vertrauten bin Hamam aus Katar
geschickt baut Platte ein globales
Netzwerk auf mit Michelle Platini an
seiner Seite
[Musik]
die Michelle Michelle ihnen hatte ich
wirklich ins Herz geschlossen
die beiden entdecken das große Geschäft
im Fußball
[Musik]
die großentwicklungen
wir waren die letzten Armen
die FIFA gegründet 1904
[Musik]
Präsident der FIFA gehört man zum Club
der mächtigsten Männer der Welt zur FIFA
gehören 211 Länder die FIFA sagt
übrigens gerne dass sie mehr Mitglieder
habe als die UNO und alle vier Jahre
organisiert sie die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
den wm-austragungsort bestimmt damals
das Exekutivkomitee bestehend aus 24
Männern
Sepp Blatter ist der Präsident
im Exekutivkomitee sitzen unter anderem
die Delegierten hologrondoner
Nikolas Leos
Ricardo da
und Michelle Platini
ihnen werden wir immer und immer wieder
begegnen
[Musik]
sie profitieren vom neuen
Geschäftsmodell entwickelt von Sepp
Blatter und Michelle Platini
Gott als dieser Obermann ist er zur FIFA
kommt ist es noch eine kleine
Organisation man spricht noch nicht von
Milliarden von Franken doch sehr Plata
besitzt den richtigen Geschäftssinn er
erhöht die Gebühren für die TV-Rechte
und gleichzeitig können die Sender mehr
für ihre Werbung kassieren und so
gewinnen alle und so wird die FIFA zu
einer richtigen Geldmaschine
[Musik]
doch hinter dem Milliardengeschäft
versteckt sich ein korruptionssystem
blatter hat damals die Marketingfirma
isl Zug mit dem Verkauf von TV-Rechten
beauftragt
im Zug tvrecht
[Musik]
im Jahr 2001
die Zuger Justiz beginnt zu ermitteln es
gibt eine Hausdurchsuchung bei der FIFA
und haufenweise Akten
das sind ungefähr
2300 schachtelungen
zu stoppen
alles was im Fußball passiert und alle
Schwierigkeiten im Fußball sind sondern
innerhalb der fußballerischen
Gerichtsbarkeit oder Rechtsprechung
gemacht werden und nicht vor ordentliche
Gerichte gebracht werden das ist nicht
mehr unsere Familie
unsere Unterlagen zeigen die
zuckerjustiz ermittelt dennoch
hartnäckig weiter jahrelang Gerüchte
dringen nach draußen
ein Journalist konfrontiert damals
Blatter damit
[Musik]
eine Million war wohl mal dabei die auf
den fifa-konto ging die dann aber
weiterging
Lounge
[Musik]
die ISL mehr geldgerüchte holen Blatter
immer wieder ein noch nie versucht
jemanden zu bestechen und andererseits
bin ich nicht beste
schauen sie mir in die Augen was meinen
Sie wie ich da stehe
mit meinen 1.300 Dienstagen sie wissen
nicht was ein Schweizer Offizier im
Range eines
regimentskommandanten als Verantwortung
trägt und ich komme dann raus als ein
als ein Betrüger nein also so nicht
nicht
[Musik]
der britische Journalist Andrew Jennings
fragt kritisch nach
können sie bestätigen oder dementieren
dass diese Zahlung für Herrn Avant war
und wenn nicht für wen
an dieser Pressekonferenz
immer wieder streitet Platte ab
dann nach neun Jahren Ermittlungen im
Mai 2010 erlässt die zugerjustiz ihre
Verfügung jetzt ist erstmals juristisch
belegt
nicht in Frage gestellt werden kann die
Feststellung dass die FIFA Kenntnis von
Schmiergeldzahlungen an Personen ihrer
Organe hatte
insgesamt sind 122 Millionen provisions
oder andere ist
der
im Exekutivkomitee im wm-wahlgremium
Sitzen also mindestens zwei Personen die
ISL Schmiergelder akzeptiert haben
und die beiden werden in wenigen Monaten
mitentscheiden wer die WM 2022 austragen
soll
inzwischen ist der isl-skandal weltweit
bekannt kurz vor dem Wahltermin
konfrontiert der BBC Journalist Jennings
die beiden
wir fragten ihn schriftlich und die
Zahlungen zu erklären keine Antwort also
versuchte ich ihn im Zürcher Luxushotel
zu fragen
Sie die Schmiergelder von der isl
kassiert
[Musik]
antwortete nicht
miteinander sprechen
haben sie Schmiergelder erhalten wofür
waren diese isl-zahlungen
[Musik]
damals hätte Sepp Blatter gewusst das
zwei Mitglieder vom Exekutivkomitee
warum hättet kommen
doch die ISL Schmiergeldzahlungen waren
öffentlich bekannt eigentlich hätte er
handeln müssen
so sieht das auch Hans-joachim Eckert
später Mitglied der FIFA Ethikkommission
sie soll Korruption bei der FIFA
verhindern
ich war fünf Jahre lang der Vorsitzende
der rechtsprechenden kann man bei der
FIFA das hängt sicherlich damit zusammen
mit meinem üblichen Werdegang in der
Justiz in dem Bereich von 30 Jahren
Bekämpfung der Wirtschaftskriminalität
und der organisierten Kriminalität
Eckhard sagt aufgrund der damaligen
Beweislage wäre der Ausschluss von Leos
und der shayda angebracht gewesen
wenn man das im Nachhinein so liest dann
hätte sicherlich die FIFA reagieren
müssen ob das jetzt der Herr Blatter
gewesen wäre oder die Rechtsabteilung
oder die Ethikkommission das wäre es
auch in der FIFA gewesen hier darauf zu
reagieren und das hat sie nicht getan
Zürich november 2010 eine Woche vor der
WM Wahl
im FIFA Exekutivkomitee sitzt auch
Michelle Platini damals Präsident des
mächtigen Fußballverbandes UEFA
9 Jahre nach der kata-wahl gibt er im
Westschweizer Fernsehen freimütig
Auskunft darüber was damals passiert ist
dieses berühmte Mittagessen vom 23
November 2010 im elisee-palast mit
Präsident Sarkozy da ist der Kronprinz
von Katar der mittlerweile Emir geworden
ist waren sie da ein wenig überrascht
sie kommen an uns
ja weil ich darum gebeten hatte
Präsident sarkozi zu sehen um ihm zu
sagen für wenig stimmen werde man sagte
mir wie organisieren ein Mittagessen ich
war einverstanden als ich dort ankam saß
auch der Emir von Katar am Tisch aber
sie haben mich nie gebeten für Katha zu
stimmen sie haben nichts von mir
verlangt nur als ich rausging rief ich
Platte an und sagte hör mal ich glaube
ich bin da an einen Ort gelangt
diese Woche vor der Menschheit ist alles
mittergasse
mit dem Staatspräsident er sarkosi
damals und derjenige
Staatspräsident im Geschäft wenn der
Kante Mithelfer mit seiner
stimmberechtigter
das
bringen
aber wenn der Staatspräsident
bis bitte
ich weiß es nicht vielleicht wollte
Präsident Sarkozy zeigen dass Frankreich
Katha unterstützt bei der wm-wahl aber
er hat mich nie gebeten für Katha zu
stimmen eine Form von Druck sie kommen
zum Mittagessen und müssen sich dann
sagen tja ihn hätte ich jetzt nicht hier
erwartet
nein ich kenne sie seit 30 Jahren so
funktioniert das ich kenne die Katara
seit 30 Jahren sie haben einen Monat
vorher in der FIFA Ihr Projekt
präsentiert ich habe es nicht nötig das
Präsident sarkozi sie mit mir zusammen
bringt
wir realisieren also es gibt politische
Einflussnahme auf höchster Ebene
fünf Nationen bewerben sich für die WM
[Musik]
USA
Südkorea Australien und Japan Favorit
sind die
usaits und
hoststimmung
Präsident Obama telefoniert und will
aber momentan
Zürich 2 dezember 2010
der Tag der wm-wahl
das
Exekutivkomitee trifft sich im FIFA
Hauptgebäude hinter verschlossenen Türen
im sogenannten borgoum drei Stockwerke
tief unter der Erde
Blatter weiß Platini und seine drei
Verbündeten werden für Katar stimmen
und
der Scherer und Leos haben isl
Schmiergelder kassiert
[Musik]
das ist natürlich eine riesen über
raschung das ist jetzt ein Knall
[Applaus]
FIFA also das Gefühl die Ölquellen
werden dort weiter sprudelt auch in 12
Jahren ich kann es fast nicht fassen das
kleine Cutter hat die großen USA und
Australien in die Schranken gewesen
wir lassen Sie nicht im Stich sie werden
stolz auf uns und auf den Mittleren
Osten sein das verspreche ich
[Applaus]
war es ein Fehler wenn man jetzt sieht
der ganze Ärger für Sie und Blatter und
für viele andere begann mit der Wahl von
Kötter
nein nein überhaupt nicht sie werden
sehen es wird die schönste WM sein
es geht politische Einflussnahmen auf
die Nomination von catter 220 aber es
gibt Nummer wir sehen in den
amerikanischen Akten dass die USA kurz
nach der Kata Wahl mit den Ermittlungen
begonnen haben
und wir stoßen in den Akten auf zwei
bekannte Namen der Shader und Leos die
beiden isl-schmiergelderbezüge
auch bei den us-ermittlungen geht es um
Schmiergelder
[Musik]
und dazu muss man sagen dass die
amerikanische Justiz aus welchen Gründen
auch immer da gibt es natürlich
Vermutungen man hätte gerne die WM
bekommen auf jeden Fall haben die
Amerikaner das gemacht was sie gut
können sie haben auch die Spur des
Geldes aufgenommen
trotzdem Schatten der Korruption bleibt
das präsidentenkarrieren nimmt vorerst
keinen Schaden
number of vots for Mr Josef es bleibt
dirty nine er wird dreimal wiedergewählt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der Pokal aus brasilianischen Händen
danke schön danke schön
nun sitzt der König der Fußballwelt also
wieder auf seinem
Thrones Afrika
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Zürich mai 2015
Vorbereitungen für den 65 FIFA Kongress
die vierte Wiederwahl von Sepp Blatter
steht an
die über 200 Funktionäre logieren in den
besten Hotels von Zürich
zeitlich stehen wir fünf Jahre nach der
kata-wahl fünf Jahre nach der Niederlage
der USA
im Luxushotel borulak genießen die
höchsten fifa-offiziellen die Bedienung
dann überstürzen sich die Nachrichten
[Musik]
alles
from
wir sind entschlossen diese Praktiken zu
beenden die Korruption auszutrocknen und
die fehlbaren vor Gericht zu bringen
die Kantonspolizisten agieren in Zivil
denn im Hotel Login auch zahlreiche
Journalisten diese fotografieren und
Berichten später vom äußerst diskreten
Vorgehen
ich habe es aus dem Radio erfahren
ich habe mir gesagt es ist ein
schlechter Film das ist nicht wahr das
kann nicht wahr sein
[Applaus]
die Polizei verhaftet 10 hohe
fifa-offizielle
Leos und der sind nicht im Büro lag die
beiden sind gar nicht angereist jetzt
werden sie international zur Verhaftung
ausgeschrieben
sie hätten garantieren sollen dass
Fußball ehrlich und sauber ist
stattdessen korrumpierten sie den
Fußball schauten auf ihr Eigeninteresse
und bereicherten sich
sie taten es immer und immer wieder ja
für ja Turnier und Turnier
der FIFA-Präsident tanzt heute nicht in
seinem Büro er ist naja ruhig und
verfolgt das Geschehen
und
kooperiert voll mit der
Bundesanwaltschaft und dann entsprechend
auch mit dem Bundesamt für Justiz
Auftritt von michael Lauber Schweizer
Bundesanwalt Seite an Seite mit der
us-justizministerin Loretta Lynch noch
ahnt niemand das bald daraus eine
Schweizer justizaffäre wird
public interest das öffentliche
Interesse an den Schweizer Ermittlungen
ist enorm deshalb haben wir entschieden
sie über den Stand unserer Ermittlungen
zu informieren ich kann bestätigen dass
die Bundesanwaltschaft zusammen mit
Justizministerin Lynch kontinuierlich
den Umfang der strafrechtlichen
Ermittlungen prüft
es ist mir eine große Ehre nun das Wort
an meiner amerikanische Amtskollegin
generalstaatsanwältin Lynch zu übergeben
[Musik]
das Problem der fußballkorruption ist
global und wir bleiben wachsam mit
unserem Bemühungen eine globale Antwort
zu finden
dieser Mann wird alles verändern der
Argentinier Alejandro bursaco
er reist ahnungslos nach Zürich und auch
er steht auf der us-fahndungsliste
Maria Roselli hat seine Geschichte
recherchiert
am Tag der Aussehen erregenden
Verhaftungen im borulak kam Alejandro
bursago zu spät zum Frühstück
wurden war er also nicht dort er nutzt
sofort die Gelegenheit und flüchtet nach
Italien er ist auch italienischer
Staatsbürger
in Italien bleibt er zwei Tage lang ohne
genau zu wissen wie er sich verhalten
soll
danach tauscht er sich mit seinem Anwalt
aus und beschließt sich der
amerikanischen Justiz zu stellen
die amerikanischen Ermittler holen ihn
ab und bringen ihn direkt nach New York
dort beginnt er mit der US-Justiz zu
kooperieren und erzählt alles was er
weiß er konnte er übergibt der US-Justiz
sein Blackberry darauf befinden sich
Tausende von E-Mails und Korrespondenzen
mit vielen fußball-funktionären so
können sie ihre Ermittlungen fortsetzen
eigentlich sind die FIFA offizielle nach
Zürich angereist um den Präsidenten zu
wählen
trotz burrulak der 79-Jährige hält an
der Kandidatur fest
militärisch gesprochen war es ein
Angriff auf die FIFA also muss der
Kommandant an Bord bleiben er darf nicht
fliehen das ist meine militärische
Erziehung ich als Chef bleibe hier
doch Blatter Gerät von unerwarteter
Seite unter Druck sein Vertrauter und
Freund Michelle Platini lanciert
zusammen mit uefa-generalsekretär Gianni
Infantino den Angriff
wir haben wie sie alle verfolgt was in
den letzten Tagen passiert ist und
ehrlich gesagt ich der die FIFA liebt
ich ein großer Bewunderer der FIFA
Geschichte ich der das seit Jahren
verfolgt ich bin empört angewidert ich
habe satt
genug ist genug
Platini ist zu mir nach Hause gekommen
und hat gesagt kandidiere nicht
ich habe ihm geantwortet wie meinst du
das ich bin der Präsident und die Wahlen
sind traktandiert ich werde den Kongress
durchführen und mich der Wiederwahl
stellen
ich habe ihm geantwortet schade es wäre
gut für deine Image wenn du die Lage
begreifst und uns verletzt
ich kann Ihnen Garantieren an der
morgigen Wahl wird eine sehr sehr große
Mehrheit der europäischen Verbände für
den Prinzen Ali stimmen
noch Arndt Platini nicht dass sein
Generalsekretär Gianni Infantino 9
Monate später auf dem
fifa-präsidentenstuhl sitzen wird
in der nächsten Monaten folgt ein
erbitterter Machtkampf zwischen den drei
Alphatieren
[Musik]
zunächst aber am 29 mai 2015 zwei Tage
nach den Verhaftungen im Büro lag Sepp
Blatter unterwegs zur Wiederwahl als
wären nichts geschehen
ganz einfach ich möchte bei euch bleiben
mit euch weiter zusammenarbeiten
man darf nicht vergessen das war ein
Angriff auf die FIFA das verletzt das
verletzt du
[Applaus]
doch der mediale Druck ist gewaltig
[Musik]
2 juni 2015 vier Tage nach der
Wiederwahl
mein Mandat hat nicht die Unterstützung
der gesamten Fußballwelt
deshalb stelle ich es anlässlich eines
außerordentlichen wahlkongresses zu
Verfügung
ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
ich habe auf Druck reagiert auch von der
amerikanischen Justiz
sie hatte vor die FIFA zu einer mafiosa
mafiösen Gesellschaft zu erklären
womöglich mit dem Leben Gedanken an das
viele Geld zu kommen
seine letzte fifa-pressekonferenz endet
mit einem Eklat
Ing
[Musik]
wir müssen hier zuerst aufräumen das hat
nichts mit Fußball zu tun ich bin gleich
zurück
nach borulak und zwei Monate nach
Blatters Abgang Michel Platini wirft den
Hut in den Ring und will die Führung des
Weltfußballverbandes FIFA übernehmen der
heutige uefa-funktionär will damit
Nachfolger von zipplatter werden Michael
Bettini ist sehr gut gestartet er hat
bereits die Unterstützung von vier
kontinentalverbänden Europa Süd und
Nordamerika und Karibik
ist also als Favorit praktisch gewählt
zwei Monate später die Journalisten
warten auf Neuigkeiten aus dem
Exekutivkomitee eine
routinepressekonferenz Bitte FIFA ist
die zwei
pressekonferenzoxet die Pressekonferenz
ist sehr stumme Stunde
warum die Ermittlungen gegen den
Weltfußballverband FIFA wegen Korruption
werden ausgeweitet die
Bundesanwaltschaft hat mit Unterstützung
der Bundeskriminalpolizei heute eine
Hausdurchsuchung beim FIFA Hauptquartier
in Zürich durchgeführt zudem wurde Herr
Josef Blatter als Beschuldigter
eingenommen und Monsieur Michelle
Platini als Auskunftsperson befragt
während einer Sitzung des FIFA
exekutives unten warten 200 Journalisten
warum dieses Theater für zwei in der
Schweiz wohnhafte Personen muss finde
ich gut an es ging darum uns zu
schreiben
abgeführt und das hätte
Freundinnen
gezeigt und der Brief Platini verlangt
im Jahr 2011 nachträglich 2 Millionen
Franken Honorar für eine Beratung die
über 8 Jahre zurückliegt über diesen
Brief werden beide stürzen
so haben sie laut Platini verhandelt wie
viel willst du eine Million von was Robe
französische Franken Dollar
einverstanden eine Million Franken pro
Jahr
engagiert als mein Mitarbeiter und für
technische hilfreich mir aber nicht
einmal Millionen
hast du ein Problem zu zahlen ja ich
kann keine Million Zahlen der
Generalsekretär verdient 300.000 ich
kann dir nicht dreimal mehr zahlen wir
werden dir einen Vertrag für 300.000
machen und ein Rest später zahlen
und eines Tages
darf der FIFA Brief geschrieben
dem
2 Millionen FIFA
Ethikkommission
genau
dafür war damals Hans-joachim Eckert
zuständig als Vorsitzender Richter der
Ethikkommission er fällt ein Urteil das
in der FIFA Geschichte einmalig ist
ja FIFA Präsident Blatter muss seinen
Stuhl räumen
ich habe damals nicht alleine
entschieden für die Ethikkommission der
Rechtsprechung kann man sondern ich habe
noch mit drei anderen Beisitzern
gemeinsam geprüft ob wir das Verfahren
öffnen oder nicht und Sie können wir
glauben dass macht man sich nicht leicht
die zwei Vorsitzenden Präsidenten der
Fußballverbände UEFA und hier der FIFA
ein Verfahren gegen sie offiziell zu
eröffnen mit der gleichzeitigen Maßnahme
dass sie vorläufig gesperrt sind
aus der vorläufigen Sperre wird zwei
Monate später eine definitive
[Musik]
es tut mir leid für den Fußball
aber es tut mir auch leid wegen mir wie
ich behandelt werde in dieser Welt der
Menschlichkeit
ich meine vielleicht ganz gut zu wissen
dass man so etwas nicht übers Knie
bricht sondern dass man sich der
Gedanken macht weil mein sie sperren
nicht so ohne weiteres aus dem
handgelenkte mächtigsten fußballmann der
Welt da wird kein Fehler machen
[Musik]
können Sie nachvollziehen dass diese
Methoden ein bisschen mafiös erscheinen
eine Million pro Jahr ja nein ein
bisschen mehr ich denke nicht ich denke
es ist ein gentlemanagement
morgen werden die Journalisten schreiben
Blatter ist am Ende Platter ist nicht am
Ende solange erlebt sie tragen dieses
Pflaster sie haben sich ein eventuell
bösartiges Melanom entfernen lassen sie
sind 79-jährig man sollte auch loslassen
können
ich kann die FIFA loslassen
aber nicht mich selbst ich bin Schweizer
Bürger ich will für meine Rechte und für
die Gerechtigkeit kämpfen
nach der Sperre aus der Traum als
fifa-präsidentschaftskandidat
ich sage die Wahrheit die ganze Wahrheit
nur die Wahrheit ich schwöre es
bitte trainiert es war sehr schwierig
ich verstehe es nicht ich habe nicht
begriffen wie das passieren konnte ich
wurde als bilanzfälscher als korrupter
als Geldwäscher bezeichnet überall in
allen Medien ich habe 20 Jahre lang für
die FIFA gearbeitet die
Weltmeisterschaft ehrenamtlich für die
FIFA organisiert es ist die FIFA die mir
Geld überweist und es ist die gleiche
FIFA die mich suspendiert weil sie mehr
Geld überwiesen hat ich versuche zu
verstehen aber es fällt mir schwer und
das ist immer noch so ja das ist immer
noch so ja ja
die beiden kämpfen bis heute um ihre
Ehre
mussten Blatter und platinigehen damit
er an die Macht kommt Gianni Infantino
platinis UEFA Generalsekretär über diese
Frage wird bis heute gestritten unser
Datenvergleich zeigt aber jetzt geht es
Schlag auf Schlag
Boro Lac Verhaftungen der Mission
Blatter Kandidatur Platini 2 Millionen
Vorwurf provisorische und schließlich
definitive Sperre Blatter Platini und
nur 20 Tage nach der provisorischen
Sperre kandidiert bereits der kaum
bekannte Gianni Infantino
[Musik]
FIFA wahlkongress 26 Februar 2016 in
Zürich
[Musik]
ich möchte heute zu ihnen aus vollem
Herzen sprechen
vor fünf Monaten hätte ich nicht gedacht
dass ich heute vor ihm stehen würde dass
ich Kandidat sein würde für das
fifa-präsidentenamt aber in der letzten
Monaten ist viel passiert die FIFA
befindet sich in einer Krise in einer
schwierigen Situation ihr Ruf ist
angeschlagen man spricht von Korruption
Gerichten Anwälten was auch immer kurz
Infantino war ein bisschen der ewige
Zweite an der Seite von Platini bei der
UEFA er stand ab und zu im Rampenlicht
beispielsweise bei den Auslosungen der
Mannschaften für die
Europameisterschaften dann verschwand er
wieder aber im Jahr 2015 als all diese
Verwicklungen und den Kriegen bei der
FIFA auftauchten naja da nimmt er seine
Chance wahr
und wenn die Situation schwierig ist
liebe Freunde gibt es zwei Optionen
entweder man versteckt sich oder man
stellt sich für mich war versteckt nie
eine Option ich wollte immer Handeln und
Tun was richtig ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seine Entourage und seine Frau feiern
er ist der richtige Mann er wird es
elegant lösen
[Applaus]
wir lesen in den Unterlagen immer wieder
von einer komplott-theorie
Infantino habe bei der Blatter Platini
Sperre eine Rolle gespielt Infantino
dementiert Energie
auf jeden Fall sollte Platini nicht
anwesend sein er war sein Gegner Nummer
eins wenn Platini da gewesen wäre wäre
er nie gewählt worden Platini wäre
Präsident es war böse artig schlau und
bösartig ein perfide Spiel
[Musik]
ihre Meinung nach war er aktiv ja er war
intelligent und aktiv und wie ich denke
er hat das gewusst ich denke Infantino
wollte zuerst UEFA-Präsident werden und
dann hat er realisiert dass der
fifa-stuhl frei wird und dann ich weiß
nicht das muss man die Ermittler Fragen
die Wahrheit wird ans Tageslicht kommen
ich kenne sie nicht ganz aber ich
orientiere mich an denen die sich dazu
äußern wollen
[Applaus]
danke dass ihr Zwischenstopp machen
verstanden
aufgewachsen ist infant mit zwei älteren
Schwester
verwende
seine Eltern kommen als italienische
Gastarbeiter in den 60er Jahren nach
Brig der Vater Hilfsarbeiter die Mutter
Kioskverkäuferin
der kleine Gianni liest italienische
Kassetten und träumt von einer
Fußballkarriere
er spielt beim FC Brig Glis
[Musik]
Jugendfreund Renaldo Arnold ist dort
Präsident
vom zweiten Mannschaften
Infantino verspricht eine neue FIFA
davon ist ein absolut notwendig die sind
[Musik]
gut gegangen ist und so weiter
ins Herkunft ab jetzt
[Musik]
sein erster Arbeitstag nach der Wahl
er beginnt mit einem Fußballspiel auf
den ersten Blick harmlos alles bekannte
Stars
alles Freunde ich habe versprochen dass
an meinem ersten Tag bei der FIFA der
Fußball zurück ist ein paar Anrufe alle
sind da Telefonate
harmlos bis auf einen bis auf diesen
unscheinbaren Mann Renaldo Arnold kein
Fußballstar sondern der Jugendfreund das
Brig
er ist vor allem ein nützlicher Freund
er ist Walliser Oberstaatsanwalt und
erkennt andre den informations-chef der
Bundesanwaltschaft
Martin kommt auch aus dem Wallis
sein Vorgesetzter heißt michael Lauber
der Bundesanwalt
Lauber leitet die Korruptionsverfahren
rund um die FIFA und UEFA
SRF redakte Oliver Washington hat
Michael laubers Karriere verfolgt
quasi über Nacht habe sich alles
verändert durch die Enthüllungen der
sogenannten Football leaks und der
Panama papers tausende von vertraulichen
Mails
das sind Dokumente Journalisten
zugespielt wurde sind das ist das riesen
Thema
ist in der Schweiz hat der Tagesanzeiger
die Dokumente ausgewertet das brisante
Ergebnis das sozusagen
die berühmten Geheimtreffen wir
vergleichen die Daten mit den uns
bereits bekannten Ereignissen und wir
staunen
das erste Treffen am 8 Juli 2015 Heike
noch vor der Sperre Blatter Platini noch
vor der Wahl infantinos ging es hier um
infantinos eventuelle Kandidatur mit der
Bibel dem ersten traf es sind der Laube
symmetrische und der Rinaldo Arnold
Arnold hat
das Treffen
informiere aber das überrascht will ein
Walliser Oberstdorf
dass der Schweiz sogar erkannt dass er
weiß wie bundeswirtschaft funktioniert
zwei Wochen nach infantinos Wahl geht es
weiter
Arnold schreibt am 5 März 2016
sehr geehrter Herr Martin könnten Sie
mich anrufen egal wann ich hätte eine
persönliche Frage danke und freundliche
Grüße Renaldo Arnold
Bundesanwalt Lauber trifft heimlich den
FIFA-Präsidenten Infantino obwohl die
Bundesanwaltschaft eigentlich wegen
Korruptionsvorwürfen rund um die
fifa-wahl von Qatar 22 ermittelt
das Treffen findet am 22 März statt
nicht etwa in der Bundesanwaltschaft
nein im Hotel Schweizerhof in Bern ein
Hotel im Besitz eines katarischen
Staatsfonds
und
im Schweizerhof befindet sich auch die
Botschaft von Katar
Geheimtreffen mit der fifa-spitze in
einem Katar Hotel und gleichzeitig
Ermittlungen ob es bei der cutter-wahl
zu Korruption kam eine heikle
Kombination
kurz danach zwei Wochen nach dem
Geheimtreffen laubers Bundesanwaltschaft
führt eine Hausdurchsuchung bei der UEFA
durch bei infantinos ehemaligem
Arbeitgeber
am UEFA Hauptsitz in mir wurde heute
eine Razzia durchgeführt denn in den
Panama papers taucht auch ein bekannter
Name auf Dani Infantino der frühere UEFA
Generalsekretär und jetzige FIFA
Präsident
der Hintergrund
Infantino hat damals mit zwei dubiosen
tv-rechte-händlern Verträge
abgeschlossen die beiden sind in den USA
angeklagt ist der neue FIFA-Präsident in
unsaubere Geschäfte verwickelt der
Verdacht wird später noch viel zu reden
geben Infantino stört dass er in den
Medien zusammen mit der UEFA Razzia
erwähnt wird er schickt seinem
Jugendfreund eine SMS
das ist natürlich kompletter Unsinn der
Schaden ist sehr groß
wenn du willst kann ich mal versuchen zu
erreichen ob die Bundesanwaltschaft eine
Medienmitteilung machen würde das gegen
Infantino kein Verfahren am Laufen ist
das wäre sehr gut
die Bundesanwaltschaft lehnt zwar ab
aber zehn Tage später trifft sich
Infantino erneut mit Laube jetzt ein
Geheimtreffen in Zürich im Restaurant oh
premier
in fantino fliegt dafür eigens mit der
Privatjet des Emirs von Katar an
all dies hätte die Öffentlichkeit nie
erfahren sollen
im Herbst 2018 werden die Football leaks
bekannt
und dann gibt es die berühmte
Pressekonferenz von Lauber
dann tritt er vor die Medien lauter
zusammen mit Martin
besten Dank für Ihre Interesse an der
Arbeit der Bundesanwaltschaft
damit bitteschön
guten Morgen am 6 April 16 wurde ein
Strafverfahren im Zusammenhang mit der
UEFA eröffnet am 22 April 16 ist es 22
und abschließenden treffen dann zwischen
mir und Janine in Zürich gekommen und
ich habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt weder in
diesem Treffen noch irgendwie sonst mit
Janine fantino oder mit vertreten der
UEFA über diese Sache gesprochen warum
sind diese Treffen nicht protokolliert
worden
das hier sind übergeordnete Treffen zu
Steuerung zu strategischen Steuerung der
Verfahren deswegen hat diese
Dokumentationspflicht der stepio nach
meiner Ansicht nach nichts zu tun mit
der konkreten Dokumentationspflicht die
diese Stereo Vorsicht für die konkreten
Verfahrens Handlung sonst müsste ich
jedes einzelne Treffen mit
irgendjemanden nur weil es die Bär oder
der Bär macht im weitesten Sinne dann
dokumentieren das würde in eine total
falsche Richtung führen dieses Treffen
nicht auch wenn sie jetzt alten Wirbel
sind jetzt dann steht nein nicht bereue
es nicht weil ich sehr ich ich kann ja
nicht meine Pflicht bereuen oder also
ich sehe das wirklich aus meine Pflicht
es zu machen wie ich ihn gesagt habe ich
mache es auch in anderen Verfahren es
ist wirklich nötig ich sage es Ihnen
wenn das nicht mehr nötig sein darf und
nicht mehr meine Pflicht sein darf dann
denke ich habe ich ein absolutes
Grundsatz Problem
[Musik]
mit Verfahrensbeteiligten
und noch etwas fällt auf bei laubers
auftritt
[Musik]
wäre
er seit gleichzeitig das zweite Treffen
Hotel
will dann Pointe sie ist das
Offenheit erzählt hat
Ronaldo Arnold mittlerweile schon per Du
mit Andre
hallo André infantinos Zug hat
Verspätung wir werden ein paar Minuten
später da sein bis gleich Gruß
sali kein Problem im ersten Stock
meeting room 3
5 Monate später
laubers Bundesanwaltschaft handelt
einige Monate später wird die
uefa-untersuchung eingestellt was
Infantino in gewisser Weise entlastet es
stellt sich natürlich die Frage ob sie
darüber gesprochen haben ob das Treffen
eine Rolle gespielt hat
weshalb die Bundesanwaltschaft das
Verfahren einstellte darüber wird noch
heute fünf Jahre später spekuliert zwei
außerordentliche Staatsanwälte ermitteln
[Musik]
die SRG konfrontiert damals Lauber mit
dem vergessenen treffen
wir haben manuell die Agenten
durchgesehen im ende letzten Jahr und
haben dieses mögliche dritte Treffen
nicht gefunden das ist ein Fehler da ist
uns etwas ein laxus passiert das kann
geschehen wenn Sie meine agend anschauen
wie viele Termine da sind muss ich das
einfach glauben ich habe nicht
verschwiegen ich lüge nicht es ist
einfach so die simple Wahrheit auch wenn
das vielleicht eine unangenehme Wahrheit
ist
Treffen
unter Druck für sich sind die
Ausführungen
untersuche getragen
auch für ihn ist die
disziplinaruntersuchungen Unabhängigkeit
wurde bundesarbeiterschaft
gegen ihn als Person
auf die disziplinaruntersuchung reagiert
michael Lauber mit einer Pressekonferenz
ich lüge nicht die geschweige auch nicht
ich weise diese beiden Vorwürfe in aller
Form zurück die ganze Diskussion zu
reduzieren auf meine Erinnerungsvermögen
und das als Kardinalsfehler zu gerade
darzustellen dass meinen Kopf fordert
das ist einfach ich muss es also sagen
es ist das ist einfach nur absolut und
Infantino kann er sich noch erinnern
worüber er mit Lauber gesprochen hat
wir sind heute im FIFA Museum in Zürich
kann ich beim besten Willen nicht genau
kennen erinnere
aber was ich mich sicherlich erinnere
petersburg gesehen untertroffen wird
Eröffnung vom konferation
das mit zum bundesarbeiter der oberste
Staatsanwalt von der Schweiz und
irgendetwas krumms Wellen machen nur die
Drehzahl schreib
Hans-joachim Eckert in der
Ethikkommission von den Geheimtreffen
wusste er nichts
ich verstehe das nicht warum man sich
hier privat treffen wusste und das ist
dieses dritte Treffen in Bern dass ich
keiner mehr daran erinnert möchte ich
also es geht in die in dem Bereich des
skurrilen in diese Situation kommen sie
als Richter des öfteren in ihrem Leben
die kollektive Amnesie in manchen
Bereichen gerade in großen
wirtschaftsverfahren oder bankverfahren
ist doch sehr tiefgreifend
aber warum hat Eckert nicht gehandelt
als die Geheimtreffen Ende 2018
aufflogen fragen wir uns
wer realisieren
Infantino baut ein Jahr im Amt das
interner Kontrollgremium die
Ethikkommission um
es gibt Neuwahlen am 11 mai 2017
wir erinnern uns
Eckert hat Blatter und Platini gesperrt
wegen der 2 Millionen Zahlung
der Weltfußballverband hat sich im
Vorfeld vor seinem kongress-
und dann kam also auch die Einladung
nach Bachrain und auch die Flugtickets
und Hotelbuchung und wir sind dann
dorthin geflogen und als wir
ausgestiegen sind und die Handys wieder
gegangen sind haben wir vernehmen dürfen
durch die Medien das die Wiederwahl der
Ethikkommission in der Form nicht mehr
ansteht der Hans Joachim Eckert und egal
ihren Platz
beide sind renommiert außerhalb vom FIFA
innere Zirkel weiß benötigt warum
Eckert und Bobbele organisieren vor Ort
eine Pressekonferenz wie hat die FIFA
ihre nichtwiderwahl begründet
ich kenne keine Begründung wenn Sie eine
haben dann bitte ich Sie darum hat die
FIFA das Ihnen gegenüber nicht begründet
ich habe keine Begründung
ich weiß dass wir dann beide gesagt
haben kann ich die Ethikkommission in
dieser Form ist tot und die wird es
nicht mehr geben
am nächsten Tag antwortet Jenny
Infantino auf Journalisten Fragen so
das ist dies ist ein ganz normaler
Ablauf
der Kongress hat entschieden mit über 90
oder so Prozent stimmen diese neuen
Mitglieder zu wählen
ich denke wir sollten daraus keine
Tragödie machen
[Musik]
hat gegenüber ihnen Herrin von dir noch
einmal eine Begründung abgegeben hattet
noch einmal hin gesprochen niemals es
gab keine Kontakt mehr
[Musik]
Trecker
insbesondere
wo im Jahr
Vermieten von Dino Leute sondern sicher
ist dass die nicht Präsident wurde
wir studieren die Akten der US-Justiz
in dieser Phase von Geheimtreffen
Gedächtnisschwund und Absetzung eckerts
passiert in den USA brisantes
gesagt
er war ein TV-Rechte Händler Präsident
der Firma torneos für die er viele Jahre
arbeitete
und er war jahrelang Teil dieses
bestechungssystems
die Aussagen von bursako fanden in der
Schweiz kaum Echo in den Medien
in Brasilien hingegen waren die
Enthüllungen aus der Fußballwelt und
auch über Katha das große Thema
Grund zur Geburt Sago sagte New York vor
Gericht am 14 November 2017 aus
der Wendepunkt wir stehen fünf Jahre vor
dem WM-Start in Katar
bursago erklärt im Kreuzverhör
detailliert weshalb die kata-wahl
korrupt gewesen sei
Infantino und seine FIFA Wissen von den
brisanten Aussagen
hier haben wir mehr als 850 Seiten
Protokoll ein großer Teil davon seine
eidesstattlichen Aussagen
und auf Seite 402 wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere steht es schwarz auf weiß
basierend auf ihren Gesprächen mit Julio
grandona welche Funktionäre erhielten
Geld für ihre Stimme bei der kata-wahl
Ricardo de chera Nicolas Leos und Julio
gordona
[Musik]
diese Aussage ist entscheidend wenn es
um die Frage geht gab es bei der Wahl
von katakoruption
Korruption also bei der Kata war laut
bursago zu dieser Zeit war Sepp Blatter
FIFA-Präsident was sagt er heute dazu
dass laut us-akten drei Stimmen korrupt
waren
wurde mit acht zu 14 Stimmen gewählt
[Musik]
diese drei laut US-Justiz gekauften
Stimmen machen den Unterschied
wäre die Abstimmung 11 zu 11 ausgegangen
hätte der damalige Fifa-Präsident
Blatter den Stich entscheiden gehabt und
blatter hat die USA favorisiert wenn man
jetzt davon ausgeht dass drei Stimmen
damals gekauft waren
dann ist es so wie bei anderen
parlamentsentscheidungen in Stadträten
Gemeinderäten dann ist dieser Beschluss
ungültig weil er eben auf kriminelle Art
und Weise zustande gekommen ist und dann
müsste dieser Beschluss nach Anfechtung
eben neu Erfolgen zu anderen Bedingungen
dann würde der Situation sein dass die
FIFA letztendlich sich überlegen müsste
was tun wir jetzt
Infantino weiß zu dieser Zeit in fünf
Jahren findet die WM in Katar statt
auf die brisanten Aussagen der US-Justiz
zum Stimmenkauf reagiert er nicht
wir möchten von ihm wissen was er heute
darüber denkt unsere Anfrage für ein
Interview vor der Kamera lehnt er ab wir
bitten ihn um eine schriftliche
Stellungnahme
und warten
währenddessen erfahren wir FIFA intern
geben die brussaco-aussagen sehr wohl zu
reden
in fantino hingegen reist um die Welt
schüttelt Hände und wirbt für seine neue
FIFA
[Musik]
die WM in Katar rückt näher und näher
Zürich 5 juni 2019 wahlkongress es gibt
nur einen Kandidaten Gianni Infantino
liebe Freunde an diesem Wahltag spricht
niemand über Krise über Skandale über
Korruption nobody tox about corruption
alles sei in bester Ordnung
ich bin stolz und glücklich dass die
Reserven die bei meinem Amtsantritt eine
Milliarde betrugen heute bei 2,75
Milliarden sind also
1,75 Milliarden mehr
[Applaus]
er wird per Akklamation wiedergewählt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielen Dank allen an meine Familie und
Freunde an alle die mich lieben oder
hassen heute liebe ich alle
während Infantino von Erfolg zu Erfolg
eilt wird Michael laubers Lage immer
kritischer
die Geheimtreffen erweisen sich als
fatal
dicke Post für den bundeanwalt michael
Lauber heute vom Bundesstrafgericht in
Berlin zona er als bundeanwalt einer
seine leitenden Staatsanwälte sowie der
Leiter des FIFA Strafverfahrens müssen
in den Ausstand treten damit stolpert
Bundesanwalt Lauber über seine
inoffiziellen Treffen mit
fifa-schaft die Orientierung verloren
die Schweizer Justiz ist mit sich selbst
beschäftigt die Gerichtskommission
empfiehlt deshalb den Parlament ihn
nicht wiederzuwählen die
Bundesversammlung ist somit
verhandlungs-
es kommt anders
müsse Michael aber
[Applaus]
guten Morgen ein bisschen
dann hören Sie mich an wenn ich noch
näher kommen
ich freue mich über diese Wiederwahl ich
bedanke mich bei einem Parlament für das
Vertrauen dass man in mich setzt und ich
möchte mich auch bedanken bei meinen
Freunden bei meiner Familie Frau ist was
sie in dieser nicht immer einfachen Zeit
getan haben und mich unterstützt haben
ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag eine
Nachfrage starten Sie
[Musik]
währenddessen in der FIFA Zürich dort
passiert Erstaunliches
die FIFA Ethikkommission fällt ein
Urteil das tiefgreifende Konsequenzen
hat
stützt auf den us-kronzeugen brussaco
gestützt auf die US-Justiz
wir lesen im Urteil
das FIFA exekutiv Mitglied habe für
seine Kata Stimme schwergelder erhalten
im Urteil ist die Aussage vom bussardo
mit anderen Worten
wir fragen uns warum stützt sich die
neue FIFA edy-kommission unter Infantino
auf die us-akten mit der
kronzeugenaussage diese Frage bleibt
unbeantwortet
wir sehen aber in den Unterlagen
die alte Ethikkommission unter Eckert
eröffnete bereits damals im Zuge der
borulak-verhaftungen das Verfahren gegen
tschecheider
das
ethikkommissionsurteil sorgt in
Brasilien für Schlagzeilen
wird wegen Korruption lebenslänglich von
allen fußball-aktivitäten gesperrt und
sie verhängt eine Buße von einer Million
Schweizer Franken also ungefähr gleich
viel wie teschera laut us-akten für
seine Kata Stimme kassiert haben soll
ist der einzige des Trios der noch lebt
Leos und gondoner sind verstorben
[Musik]
trotzdem klaren Urteil
they Shader behauptet nach wie vor nie
Bestechungsgelder akzeptiert zu haben
auf CNN Brazil gibt er Auskunft
warum ermittelt die US-Justiz gegen sie
selbst
einer von denen war der die WM in den
USA begraben hat
sie rächen sich
in den USA hätte stattfinden sollen sich
sie wissen es
hätte nicht damals nach diesem
kommissionsentscheid infant
geben müssen ob und wie sich dieses
Urteil auswirkt auf die Vergabe an Katha
was sagt Infantino zum brisanten techno-
keine Reaktion keine öffentlichen
Stellungnahmen wir stehen drei Jahre vor
dem WM Start in Katar
eines von zahlreichen Videos aus dem
Internet für ihn haben die Bauarbeiten
in Katar vor
jetzting feeling and when you see es ist
ein großartiges Gefühl und wenn man die
Arbeit sieht wenn man die Schwingungen
spürt das ist magisch
[Musik]
währenddessen im politischen Bern
die Geheimtreffen Infantino Lauber haben
schwerwiegende Konsequenzen für die
Schweizer Justiz
[Musik]
Behörde und zum Schluss dass du mich
erlaubnispflichten zum Teil schwer
verletzt hat der Michel
arbeitungsgericht und immerhin
als Bundesverwaltung
schwer verletzt hat und vor allem und
das ist entscheidende Punkt seit
Bundesverwaltung
vorsatzlich Unwahrheit über das letzte
Treffen erzählt haben und damit Zeitz
Gericht eigentlich weggegangen
dass ich keiner der vier Teilnehmer mehr
an das Treffen erinnern können soll
erscheint wenig glaubhaft
[Musik]
nun geht der doch schneller als gedacht
der in Ungnade gefallene Bundesanwalt
mich erlauber hat vorzeitig auf Ende
August gekündigt
nach seinem Rücktritt zieht sich die
Schlinge enger um noch Bundesanwalt
michael Lauber der außerordentliche
Staatsanwalt will gegen Laube ein
Strafverfahren eröffnen und beantragt
die Aufhebung von laubers Immunität
ist nicht zu stoppen
er stimmt in Katar wm-helfer ein
Präsidentin fantino
hello
[Applaus]
you feel good
great we can show wir können der ganzen
Welt zeigen das Cutter ja die ganze
arabische Welt alle willkommen heißt für
ein unglaubliches Erlebnis
[Musik]
ihr seid das Herz die Seele und das
Lächeln der WM
[Applaus]
ich zähle 1 2 3 und dann Katar
gut
[Applaus]
wir wollen von der FIFA wissen
hat der Shader die eine Million Franken
Buße bezahlt
die FIFA gibt auf diese Frage keine
Auskunft
[Musik]
aber wir realisieren im Hintergrund
laufen Gerichtsverfahren
[Musik]
denn der Shader akzeptiert die Buße und
das Urteil der fifa-ethikkommission
nicht
er rekoriert und sieht das Urteil weiter
wir verlangen bei den Gerichten Einsicht
in die Entscheide und wir staunen erneut
das Verfahren hat jetzt infantinos
Rechtsabteilung übernommen sie
verteidigt den Standpunkt der
Ethikkommission vor dem Obersten Gericht
zum Bundesgericht Lausanne
und die FIFA gewinnt
das Bundesgericht bestätigt im Februar
dieses Jahres
derer ist schuldig der Korruption
mit anderen Worten
nomination 2022 mindestens drei Stimmen
[Musik]
wie die Situation jetzt ist ob und in
welcher Form die FIFA auf diese
Entscheidung des Bundesgerichts zu
reagieren hat
entscheidet der Herr Infantino
was denken sie in dem Bereich denke ich
nicht
warten erhalten wir endlich eine Mail
von Gianni Infantino viele Fragen
bleiben unbeantwortet zum
Bundesgerichtsurteil erhalten wir eine
Zeile
es gibt keinen Entscheid der FIFA
Ethikkommission in dem von
Bestechungsgeldern im Zusammenhang mit
Qatar die Rede ist
die Antwort vom Johnny in fontinisch
nachweislich falsch wenn er schrieb der
Korruption geben
wie lautete infantinos Motto bei seiner
Wahl zum FIFA-Präsidenten
es gibt zwei Optionen entweder man
versteckt sich oder man stellt sich man
versteckt sich und wartet bis alles
vorüber ist oder man stellt sich und
handelt für mich war verstecken nie eine
Option ich wollte immer handeln
[Musik]
und ich fürchte mich nicht Verantwortung
zu übernehmen und voranzugehen
[Musik]